oiler continue to investigate properties
of numbers specifically the distribution
of prime numbers one important function
he defined is called the Phi function it
measures the break ability of a number
so given a number say n it outputs how
many integers are less than or equal to
n that do not share any common factor
with n for example if we want to find
the Phi of 8 we look at all values from
1 to 8 then we count how many integers 8
does not share a factor greater than 1
with notice 6 is not counted because it
shares a factor of 2 well 1 3 5 & 7 are
all counted because they only share a
factor of 1 therefore Phi of 8 equals 4
what's interesting is that calculating
the Phi function is hard except in one
case look at this graph it is a plot of
values of Phi over integers from 1 to a
thousand now notice any predictable
pattern the straight line of points
along the top represent all the prime
numbers since prime numbers have no
factors greater than 1 the Phi of any
prime number P is simply P minus 1 to
calculate Phi of 7 a prime number we
count all integers except 7 since none
of them share a factor with 7 Phi of 7
equals 6 so if you're asked to find Phi
of 20 1377 a prime number you would only
need to subtract one to get the solution
20 1376
Phi of any prime is easy to compute this
leads to an interesting result based on
the fact that the Phi function is also
multiplicative that is Phi a times B
equals Phi a times Phi B if we know some
number n is the product of two primes P
1 and P 2 then Phi of n is just the
value of Phi for each prime multiplied
together or P 1 minus 1
times p2 minus one